The screenwriter of 2011's Green Lantern has
finally gotten around to seeing Deadpool 2
- and when he stuck around for the credits,
he got an unexpected surprise.
One of the highlights of Deadpool 2 is the
collection of epilogue scenes cut into its
credit sequence, in which Reynolds' Wade Wilson
travels back through time to fix the mistakes
of the past.
And the mistakes aren't just from the movie
- they're also mistakes from the real Ryan
Reynolds' career.
One of the jokey scenes sees Wilson go back
in time to the moment when Ryan Reynolds first
reads the script for the critically reviled
2011 superhero film Green Lantern, which wound
up bombing at the box office.
So in order to make sure this reality never
actually comes to pass, Deadpool shoots the
real-life Reynolds in the head, spraying blood
all over the pages of the Green Lantern script.
"If you could rate the Green Lantern on a
scale of 1 to 10?"
"One!
It's a one!"
"It's a one!"
The scene has left audiences roaring with
laughter - but imagine how it'd feel to be
Marc Guggenheim, one of the screenwriters
for the Green Lantern movie, watching the
scene play out.
Actually, you don't have to imagine, because
Guggenheim shared his response on Twitter
after finally seeing Deadpool 2, saying
"Just saw Deadpool 2.
Well played, @VancityReynolds.
Well played."
It's a professional response to a pretty savage
joke, but you shouldn't feel too bad for Guggenheim.
Not only does he share the credit - and the
blame - for the Green Lantern script with
three other writers, he's also gone on to
great success since then as one of the architects
behind the CW's successful Arrowverse.
So he can take a joke.
Meanwhile, Warner Bros. is planning to reboot
the Green Lantern franchise, promising to
do it right this time.
But if they don't?
Well, no problem.
After all, Deadpool still has that time machine.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!